hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm gonna be giving
three people the chance to win some
free training where basically you're
gonna be receiving the exact
tools how you can find a free
house this is just absolutely incredible
i'm thinking what are you talking about
about a free house
well as you probably saw on my winners
on a wednesday interview last week with
crept
from crepton conan wasn't incredible he
talked about his house
as effectively a free house i've been
doing a lot of deals with a lot of
celebrities
some of them um i haven't put on youtube
for confidentiality reasons
some i have some deals i've been doing
myself but when you buy a house
really cheap like the one that cred
bought was 43 000 pounds
and then you push the value up and and
then effectively you can refinance it
rent it out and pull all your money out
when you know how to do that and i've
taught a lot of celebrities
i've taught a lot of students when you
learn that skill then
you can number one do it yourself and
recycle your money
number two you can borrow other people's
money
and recycle in and out in and out in and
out you can package and sell the deals
up and pass them on
the skill is being able to find
properties that are what we call brr
properties
buy refurbished refinance rent
properties now here's what i'm going to
be offering today this is ridiculous
because three people are going to
receive my
advanced top-end training on buy
refurbished refinance
master class training and the training
is a 1 000
training course it's a six-week training
program you can do it from home
from the comp comfort of your home and
this is what the rich people are doing
and the people that have gone through
this training is completely transformed
their lives financially they've been
able to find the right kind of
investment properties
they can sell them joint venture on them
or whatever they want to do so
if you want to receive the training for
free okay i've never given this training
away for free before
then i'm going to tell you what to do in
a moment to get access to the training
for free
where you can enter into a free
competition but first let me just tell
you this there's only three figures
that you need to be able to calculate to
get really really good at doing these
deals okay the first figure is you need
to be able to get a cheap purchase price
so you can do this by going to auctions
on the bar refurbished finance
masterclass i teach you how to buy
pre-auction and post auction this is the
smart way to do it
at the moment there's so many investors
queuing up to buy properties
but on the buy refurbishing finance
master class you're going to learn how
to
strategically buy properties at auction
really cheap that's the first figure you
need to know
purchase price second figure is build
cost
refurb cost it is so important that you
know
how to find cheap and reliable builders
it's important that you can get builders
working for you fast
even if a builder walks off site like
it's happened to me
you can quickly replace them immediately
and get the job finished to a
fast and good standard and then the
third
figure is end value now it's really
important that you have exit strategies
because when you're trying to refinance
it's possible that the property could
get down valued
it's possible there could be a problem
so you need to have an exit strategy of
either
sale or refinance which means that you
have a safety blanket should it go wrong
and when you're doing buy refurbished
refinance you need to have the three
figures
work the formulas out have the exit
strategies to hand
and do it professionally and properly so
how do you win
the access to the bar refurbishment
finance master class i'm gonna leave a
link in the description
okay the link in the description all you
need to do is click on the link in the
description
and it will tell you exactly what you
need to do to enter into the prize draw
where three people not one not two three
people
are going to be receiving free access to
the entire
buy refurbished refinance master class
i'm really excited
the reason i'm giving away for free is
because i know that times right now are
hard
and there's some people that are
struggling and there's nothing i love
more
than seeing people start from the bottom
and end
at the top so whether you're an investor
already whether you're just starting out
whether you're 15
16 years old and you have no money or
whether you're 50 years old
and you want to recycle your cash click
the link below learn
how to do buy refurbished refinance
masterclass
and maybe you could learn for free with
me with my top end training
just by clicking the link in the
description
if you want to see what happened with
crept from krept and konan's
by refurbished finance property you can
check it out right here
also don't forget of course you need to
be subscribed to the channel to enter
the competition
so subscribe if you're not already
subscribed and then to enter into the
competition to potentially win the free
training
then click the link below and follow the
instructions
do it do it now and let's see you on the
other side
[Music]
you